we've done like combining the whole
numbers right but now I want us to
combine fractions right so if I say for
instance huh a quarter because we have
halves and quarters before but now what
a half or a quarter following this
patent how do I write this in terms of
numbers maybe someone hasn't said
something yet yeah tonight very good the
of is the times right okay
now Before we jump into an answer right
and this is what your pencil is for
let's draw this thing okay let's draw
this so if I have a square here that
represents one hole okay represents one
one hole I can divide this up in order
to get some fractions okay half of the
corner do the quarters first okay let's
do the corners best so I'm gonna divide
this up into four I guess I'll do it
like this their quarters it's not
perfect but you get the idea right so
I've got one two three four corners now
if I just want hard to record up I'm
gonna if you've got another color okay
I'm gonna take one of the quarters I'm
gonna slice it right down the middle
like this that great thing there is half
of one of the quarters right now see
this green rectangle I've got here right
how many of these green rectangles can I
fit in the hole yeah I can fit eight
right like if I put a few more lines in
you can see I've got eight of these
right there's one two three four five
six seven eight
so in green what I have shaded in is 1/8
because there are eight of them in the
hole so it's 1/8 right and you can see
just like before 4 here to here right
it's 1 times 1 that gives you a
numerator and then it's
times four that gives you the
denominator okay this is a bit weird
because it's completely different to
addition right remember addition we said
our 1/2 plus 1/2 right you add the
numerators don't you but you leave the
denominators and that would be 1 but
with multiplications the different
happens and you can see visually wine
this do something a little different in
the more challenging how about two
thirds of the corner before you jump in
an answer how would you draw it what
would it look like start with a square
you put it down your page put on your
page what you think it would look like
I can see some droids you've got your
quarters there
you're a nurse to start with that now if
I want not have a quarter but two-thirds
of a quarter you look at say one of them
and you say well I want I want 2/3 of
this shape so if I divide it up into
it's like that okay I want two of those
right there's one and there's food okay
now they don't ask the question just
like before how many of those things can
I fit in the entire shape right and if
you put some extra lines you'll see Josh
do you want to suggest 12 okay so I've
got one two three four five six and then
I've got seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve okay
there are twelve of these smaller
rectangles and here I've got two of them
right now just to confirm this just like
we did here how would you rewrite this
sentence with all the numbers in place
yeah awesome okay
just like before because we're
multiplying you multiply the numerators
you multiply the denominators on the top
you get 12 and on the bottom so I - and
now the bottom you're gonna get 12 just
as Josh said this is really cool we
could stop there but in this particular
example we can go a little bit further
can't we what could we do
oh yeah Ethan yeah very good sir I could
say like 2 over 12 is equivalent to 1
out of 6 and that makes sense because if
you have a look at this now if I put in
a few less lines like say take out that
one
that one look at that now this is the
same shape I didn't change any of the
lines I just got rid of some of them and
now you can see look there's one two
three four five six one six design make
sense